this meal outcome did a lot peace be
with you what have we got on the table
today you've tuned in every week new
show and you see something different got
to throw bond today I like to send a
special shout out to all the brothers
down in irvine was at Irvine Texas
Irving Texas my brother Nabil got me
this gift and we're wearing here in the
Dean show usually I'm in a suit tie but
today we're just chilling so we got the
Cato kabani kimani it's a kabani haha
what is it coincidental one of my
students also that I trained in Gracie
be presented jitsu he's the K that's a
special case a shout out to him too and
we got our next guest coming up 10 year
old author so far Abu Bakr we'll be back
we'll be talking about what we all love
to talk about this beautiful way of life
don't going on don't go anywhere we'll
be right back there's that be the Dean
show
this is the this is the thing you know
this is the danger is the name you know
this is the thing you know you can sing
too yeah so far how are you doing get
handler hamdulillah you like to throw I
ever seen Eddie in the thobe yeah I got
the race car driver stripes too huh
mm-hmm where's your throat how oh gosh
y'all luck so how you been I'm getting
high on Zara so we had you on the show
some time ago you're back again and
you're the author 10 years old what
grade are you in now I I'll handle I I'm
10 and the eighth grade your knee eighth
grade and last time we had a yawn the
show you had authored how many books was
it deep to now you're the author of how
many three so you've been busy night now
you got another book yeah okay I got
some gift here and I assume that the
books are in there they're in here okay
so think okay let's go over these books
again what it was the first one
strangers okay you did that one before
things every kid should know strangers
okay because there's a lot of crazy
people out there so you want to make
sure that you don't end up getting
kidnapped you don't end up getting
stolen right so you got to know who the
strangers are so you can protect
yourself I assume that's what this book
is about we talked about that before
right okay so then the other one about
fire yeah what's this one called it's
things we could should know for fire
what's the new one um things in kitchen
no we do suiza cycling okay tell us
about this new book now well when I
began we fry I'm finding a copper to
help kids about ice and write about I
felt I saw the water cycle
in a website and I thought this would be
a great idea if i could write about this
book and help kids about so I asked my
mouth i could write about it and she
thought it was a great idea so who I
started reach researching the book and I
wrote the book masha'Allah do you plan
on doing more books I'm working on life
fourth book coaches the importance of
seeking knowledge oh that's a really
good topic the importance of seeking
knowledge yes how important it is it to
seek knowledge knowledge is very
important for each of us to acquire you
see God the greatest says our man
whoever understanding and those who
don't have understanding alike only man
I've understanding no there's you can't
compare the two people of understanding
who who have gained knowledge and people
who are just living life according to
their desires it's not the same yes
right tell us you also have a new
nickname you want to share that with us
today my nickname was a bucket I I have
a nickname because he was the pasta
sauce on his best friend and he was a
thick in the cave with the pie was
awesome he was the high life of the
someone who uses money to help a lot of
people he's my favorite companion so I
wanted to be named after him I also
heard your international speaker yes and
you're only ten yes what do you speak
about in sogndal I am international
speaker I speak I speak up I give let I
give a speech on mom from parents about
the fossils on being gentle and patient
around children because the person was
the greatest person or our children and
rehearse need to treat kids like kids
not adults give us some more tips on
this well one of his companions at NASA
America on her it said the messenger of
allah had the best disposition among
people one day he sent me in a around
and I said by allah i will not go but it
was on my mind i would do as a prophet
sallallahu ala had ordered I want until
I came upon children playing in the
street then that messenger of allah so
I'm arrived and caught me by the back of
my neck I looked at him and found him
smile he said
nickname of an ass did you go I asked
you to go I said Owen o Messenger of
Allah yes I am going you seen many pairs
of the angrier if they asked her trial
to run around and he decided to plan
today how are the Prophet Sal Allahu
Allah some was picture when he found a
play and just kindly awesome if he had
done Lydia tastin the hospital allows
the I mean and as I realized the he had
not so and he said he was going to do it
your parents need to realize our gentle
want the prophets awesome was around
kids and high that they too need to be
pretty tree she cares with Persia and
gentleness so from the story that you
just narrated that the Prophet peace be
upon him he sent him on a task on an
errand like you said but then he being a
kid he found other kids and started
playing with them yes he got distracted
asst tracted and then the Prophet peace
be upon him we're not looking for and
then he found them and did he didn't
even scold him right he didn't yell at
him he didn't hit all none of that
what'd he do he just counted after for
you done what he had asked that did it
yeah so then you take this example and
then you you share with the parents
right yeah that how they should how they
should be with the children again yes
they shouldn't be scolding them yelling
at you treat them with patience and
gentleness patience and gentle keywords
gentleness and patience we all need a
dose of that oh yes and who's the best
example the Prophet saws the prophet
whose uh he was the best in my being who
ever lived what about Jesus he was you
all the more we all them were good all
the prophets awesome what did they come
with different messenger did they come
with a different message nobody all came
with the same message what was the
message that Jesus Moses even the one
God and His Messenger that was it now
what is the difference between let's say
if you are following Jesus or Moses or
Abraham or of your following Muhammad
there's no difference as long as you
follow what their books say and you fall
on the right path so all of their books
call people to worship the Creator not
the creation right yes and that's what
the last and final messenger came
same thing yes ok so moving along your
international speaker you give this
advice how about some people who try to
make Islam out like it's a bad religion
that Mohammed or Islam is about
terrorism what do you say I say they
should find the proper resources and
research it and then it get it then make
the that make the judgment ok so really
be open-minded about learning you to the
open minded really research it how about
hang out with some Muslims yes if they
see you on the street could they come up
to you and you can you can share aslam
with them yes what is this la mean as
llamas joke separate is that correct
Islam means to you get me some submit to
the one and only God which is who's a
lot and who to believe in this profit
which is Moses oh that's very simple
submit to only God only the creator and
we'll be right back with more would take
a break how's that you got time for some
more yes ok inshallah we'll be right
back with Abu Bakr what do you prefer I
was a fire Abu Bakr I Baleka okay I was
with Abu Bakr here on the Dean show so
cool who Allah say he I lost one God is
one the maker of mankind exactly a lot
was somewhat lost self-sufficient he
doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on the seventh day okay I
really had a problem with that even
before i do anything about a slum god
resting sounds like a week guy yeah um
lemme I'll it while I'm you let he
begets not he doesn't have any children
nor is he a child or born of anything or
anyone
well MB akula hope to fly and there is
nothing called equal or comparable to
him at all nobody nothing Jesus no
nobody nobody is comparable to the
crater nothing yeah and that right there
was in its essence what I believe
naturally
back here on a Dean show with Abu Bakr
and we talked about Prophet Muhammad you
gave a great example of how he was
patient and dad tell us and gentle why
is it important to be gentle and patient
with kids because of the possible on the
bus human being who ever lived but was
patient gentle with children then we
should be also patient under oath kids
because he's the example exactly is
surely the role model of all the Muslims
yes and what is it you mentioned Muslims
so usually I'll define or there'll be a
little a lower third here explaining
what a Muslim is people are seeing it
right now you can't see it but what is a
Muslim what does it mean to be a Muslim
I'm lesson was one who submits two god
and his messenger ok so you submit to
God and you obey the messengers right
yes because but do you worship the
messenger you know you don't wash up the
Senate do you worship Jesus no you don't
worship Jesus worship the god of Jesus
you are you worship the god of Jesus the
one who Jesus fell on his face and
prayed to yes that's who we worship yes
now do we only believe in Mohammed no we
believe in all the prophets starting
from the first mind created from adam to
Abraham look son it Jacob and the tribe
Moses June Jesus the the last Papa's o
muhammad saw some piece of your father
are so we believe in all those messages
you mentioned who you mentioned you know
really and there's many more so we
believe in all of them all of them yes
all the ones that are mentioned in the
Quran and other than the year I'll them
day you know you you don't worship them
but you worship Allah who's the creator
out loud but it's part of the belief to
believe in these messages yes your name
like Jesus want to leave them then we
don't worship them don't worship them
yes why would why would people why why
that doesn't make sense why would you
worship a messenger like Jesus or why
would you worship a man or a woman or
anything in creation it makes sense to
worship only the one creator yes because
if you wash your courage and then you
know has to be only one God because if
someone says that they believe in a
woman and someone else says they believe
in the child's one else is a mat which
undo
we know it's correct only we know that
Allah is the creator have everyone and
everything so we should worship Him only
okay yeah I like that because a human
being so much as I want to worship the
man human beings i want to worship the
child human being no we worship the
maker of the human being yes that's it
ok so moving along why why do you think
now a lot of kids your age you know you
don't see them writing books how did you
get involved in writing books where a
lot of other kids are just involved in
playing video games and you know not
really doing something as serious as you
did you know to write a book that you're
like one in a million well because my
mom and my sister started writing a book
I wanted to also write a book and help
kids so I started writing on strangers
because I want I was concerned about the
kids safety and I wanted them to be safe
I'm gonna wrote the fire book so people
know how to escape out of a fire and
they want a cycling book so people can
recycle and hope the environment okay so
your parents were being good role models
your pit so your parents are being good
role models yes darling good one that's
really good see that's very important
now because you know if the parents are
at home listening to gangsta rap right
gangster you listen to gangster rap know
you want to be a gangster never never
that's right if the painted the parents
at home are fit you know faking the funk
and you know they there you know
listening to gangsta rap then usually
you know the kids are gonna follow that
bad example exactly yeah so thank god
they're not doing that you know they're
doing good things and you're following
along good examples are you happy yes
now you're on the Dean show yeah I'm
doing luck so talk to us about the Quran
have you memorized more Quran since the
last time we've spoken yes which one
which one you know a short surah what I
sir do you remember that what's the one
you were cited last time you were here I
said it I love us what about what acid
you know that one do you know the
meaning also yes can you go ahead and
recite it matter he lalasa by the time
in
and Santa Fe who's barely Madison lost
and then ladina Avenue I'm real sorry
Hattie or twice I will hack you at
awesome so except those who believe and
do righteous good deeds I recommend 0
and other churches i recommend one other
tuitions that is so powerful that is so
powerful that was from the verbatim word
of God the Quran yes you memorized the
portion of it there said what I said
indeed all mankind everyone's in Los
except those who believe and do
righteous the correct they believe in
the one creator the maker of mankind the
Creator and they do what Righteous gonna
do righteous good deeds and they they
recommend data to the truth advise
recommend call people to the truth i
recommend as education patience and
perseverance beautiful beautiful we're
gonna take a break with that and we
write back to wrap it up with abu bakr
so far here in the d shop Esther I'm re
come on Malcolm I am Allah can we just
finished of course about the fifth of
liquor and drop that with a model
Institute here in chicago and i'm
recording this message especially for
Dean shell i would like to sign one of
the things that we learned today that
the prophet saw something whenever he
raised his hand and something in myself
that it's been
under Times reported in the processor
races and who's leaking go out but
something may be new for some of us
little nemesis woman every time you
raise his hand it's both hands were
touching each other we never reported
before something present and they're
like separated from each other you
always bring them together in begging
and asking a mosque a note on it sooner
you should care about practicing now
lost marathon except from all of us
thank you very much married some things
what are you mad man watch TV show back
here in addy show with Abu Bakr so far
and we left off with you reciting a aya
from the verbatim word of god there's no
other book like it in the world you know
that right there's no other book like it
in the world it's from the Creator it's
a living miracle for everyone who wants
to examine it test it no way yes that it
can come from anybody other than the
Creator yes by God because when people
read the qur'an to see and try to think
if as man they try to look at they try
they read the Quran that I know that is
then they realize that that it's not
created for a man but it's creative it's
the speech of guy is the speech of the
Creator yes right so it's the verbatim
word of God the speech of the crater
that's amazing so tell us now you an
author you're like we said 10 years old
you're in college yeah where you
graduated University no not yet no well
I'm joking what's the what you're in
which grade now again I am an 8th grade
author 8th grade and you're even
planning your fourth book right did you
ever get to do some Dawa did you ever
get to
you know talk to some some of the not
yet Muslims and explain Islam the
Articles of Faith to five pillars to
people yes yeah yeah how did I go I want
to find because the people that I didn't
write mashallah we're very understanding
and they met Muslims before but they
didn't become Muslim but they were
conference outside was the lift shoes
and that's a beautiful thing we don't
have to it's not our job to convert
anybody it's just our job to share to
invite people it's a it's a it's then
that it's god I love what if allah wants
he will turn wasn't trying to person was
to a Muslim to become a Muslim but if
Allah does not watch he'll never become
awesome that's it the crater guides we
just have to invite and share yeah
delivered a clear that's it why because
we care yes because you want all of your
ID not to go to hvar but to go to Jenna
now I've noticed you're wearing some
jeans and a sweater and I'm wearing like
a dope so if you become a Muslim some
people think like you got to be an Arab
or you got to wear this dope now is that
true no I'm Muslim could be from
anywhere it doesn't matter if he's black
or white every he's from somewhere else
every sort of China or America and
listen could be anyone and you gotta
wear the thoe you don't have to worry
good weird if you aren't you don't want
to you don't have to wear long as you
have modest dress yeah is that right all
right okay and I think it's pretty
comfortable I've never actually worth
over on I think I did once for haja with
yusuf estes but it's this is a one of
the fewer times so you know you were
hope sometimes huh there's a picture
like when you go back you know Jesus we
believe in one of the greatest messages
that got sent and there's a it's called
the sermon of the mount and they
actually have a picture of him wearing
what would resemble a thobe you know
it's white and it's like a thought so
interesting so your your goal is to
memorize the Quran inshallah inshallah
so this is a miracle you know that many
kids your age and some younger some
older have memorized the Quran and
you're one of those
who r has a goal in sha allah to
memorize it gosselin right any advice
that you have before we leave for other
kids who are confused in life they're
your age younger older but they're stuck
you know doing bad things maybe they
don't have good examples they turn into
the Dean show maybe the all to do is
listen to gangsta rap maybe they're
disrespectful to their parents they
don't listen and now they're looking at
you as a good role model what example
what would you say to them I say I would
say to them don't do not listen to music
and try to be the best role model you
can be for other people and try to write
books and if you can't get them
published it's okay then you could at
least you tried and that's what's
important maybe you can share that book
with other people who are your friends
and/or and then the friends can share
the book with their friends and you can
even write a copy of the book and you
can press it onto your friends instead
of listening to like bad music music and
I want and they should listen to parents
listen to their parents so instead of
wasting their time listening to like
gangsta rap they can spend time reading
and powering their mind yes yeah and be
open-minded about learn juice and be
open mind about learning the truth okay
great advice thank you for again for
being with us on the Dean show we
started with peace we run with peace
peace be with you p gfg also and that
was a far nori Abu Bakr nickname and his
new book reduce reuse and recycle go
green so when you have young kids at
this age who are empowering themselves
their minds who are reading and then
actually as the young safaris actually
authored three books going on for you
know when the kids are involved in good
things and their parents are helping
nurture this good what can this society
expect tomorrow it can expect that we'll
have a strong society because it has
strong family base and then you have
strong kids coming up or
developing themselves the personalities
their behavior is in line with what's
good they're cutting out all the
gangster rap and all the bad things that
are out there because their parents are
doing a good job raising them so if
you're a parent out there who's watching
this hope that you got to benefit and
you get motivated to connect your child
with the Quran to make sure that their
friends are good friends who are also
motivating them who are doing good
things you know so you can tomorrow have
a great investment because we know all
the wealth that we acquire we're leaving
it behind and one of the things that
stays after we leave this life and we go
to the next and we're in the grave is a
righteous child supplicating to the
crater for you so make sure that you're
investing with your children now you're
helping them to become the best in
society and avoiding them becoming the
worst in society because what kind of
estman do you have then so connect with
your Creator call upon the crater
constantly and let us invest in these
children today so they can be the best
in society and we'll see you again next
time here in the Dean show until then
peace be with you jihad often
mistranslated as holy war the word jihad
means to struggle Islam does not preach
violence it does not preach vicious holy
war it certainly does not condone terror
and suicide bombing Islam preaches
compassion tolerance and justice find
the truth about Islam call toll-free 877
why Islam order your free copy of the
Koran today I'm not afraid to stand
alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stay alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if Allah is by
my side I am not afraid to stay
do you 101 it slightly it roll then
everybody watch the show the show Ready
Steady if never eat something why you
buried some things what if my man watch
teen shows the deed show